yeah i mean when i was 17
i did experience homelessness and
it was a very very very scary time um
i was a i was a feisty you know
opinionated strong-minded teenager um
and i also had a mother who was
feisty and opinionated and strong-minded
and that kind of at that stage when
you're 17 years old
and you know you're going through that
teenage you know experience it's it's it
can cause turmoil and a little bit of um
let's say hostility in the household and
we we we had we had a you know a family
a quite a big family i've got uh five
brothers and sisters so yeah it was just
it became it became a bit too much for
me and i was someone who knew exactly
what i wanted to do and how i was going
to do it and sometime that differed from
what my mom wanted so yeah one day we
had a massive argument and i packed my
bags and i left and yeah i was homeless
and
it was extremely scary
i bet it was i bet it was i mean
you then went on eventually to be
represent your country at long john in
2004 in athens in 2008
at the beijing olympics what happened
along the road for you to turn things
around from being homeless saying i'll
see you
to actually becoming an olympic athlete
wow oh my gosh there was a lot that
happened between um then and actually
making the olympics um
well first of all i i when i initially
left home i you know stayed in a few
hostels and then i found myself at
a center point emergency hospital for
young hostel for young people and
you know
for me it was
a really rude awakening of how many
other young people there were that were
homeless you know they were experiencing
the same thing as me and
um
it was it was it was a very very
challenging time and i know that at the
time for me
trying to just do one step at a time
just to get myself in a place where i'm
actually living an adult life was
difficult so my athletics had to go on
the kind of back burner for a year or so
but then i was able to find a coach and
who i stayed with my whole career and
within i think two years of
being homeless staying hostels you know
having no one to turn to
um other than you know people like
center point who really really supported
and helped me um
it was it was two years later i became
i got back into long jump and i
i was ranked number two in the world in
the long jump um and it was just such a
i i know that for me i had that passion
to get back to track and field but that
was one of the things that really helped
me to keep moving forward each step in
that journey and that transition and
then two years after that i made my
first olympic games when i was 24 years
old so it was quite a journey um but it
was it was it was all of everything that
i went through really really helped
build that character you know when
you're standing out there in front of
you know 90 000 people and i'm scared
it's nothing as scary as kind of facing
homelessness and being on the streets so
wow wow um tell us about the
homelessness uh campaign from center
point this christmas
yeah well i am i'm so honored it's it's
it's it's really surreal to me to have
kind of gone full circle and now be an
ambassador for the charity and and it's
really close to my heart to be able to
work with center point on this christmas
campaign this year um
youth homelessness is at a five year
high
like you said earlier there's nearly 30
000 young people that are on the streets
and that are going to be homeless and
facing homelessness this winter that's
not the whole year that's just this
winter alone and you know it's such a
scary you know
thought to think that there's going to
be 33 of those that are actually going
to sleep on the streets they're actually
going to sleep in a park you know on a
park bench
the weather that we had the last few
days minus seven degrees imagine there's
young people sleeping out in that so
it's really really important we really
want to raise this awareness to what's
going on the pandemic has made it really
really difficult um but we really really
need some donations so that centerpoint
and their staff can continue to help
these young people um and i would like
to say if there are any young people
that are homeless or facing homelessness
right now they can get in contact with
centerpoint dot org dot org dot uk where
there's some
information they can get but there's
also amazing staff are there to help
they don't have to do this alone they
really don't it's very very scary and i
know it is but
it does get better and it can get better
and you know that's why it's so
important to me because i want them to
see that look you can go on to achieve
your dreams you can go on to turn
everything around and basically show
what you're capable of
what an amazing ambassador you are thank
you so much for speaking to us so
articulately about it as well this
morning much appreciated thank you very
much thank you